[Music]
you know Americans are stocking up on
bread and water and toilet paper yes
toilet paper you've seen the pictures
you've probably been in line at the
store but tonight we'll tell you what
else your fellow citizens are buying in
big numbers national correspondent
William la jeunesse shows us from Los
Angeles Coliseum guns how can I help you
from New York to California with
everything rapidly declining it's now or
never
the Colorado a little bit of maybe I
won't be able to get it tomorrow a
little bit of uncertainty gun sales
around the u.s. shooting sky-high
they're like literals homme bees they
don't care they just want something they
don't care what it is what you know make
model doesn't matter just give me
something that's all they want the FBI
says background checks surged to a near
record of three million in February I'm
afraid of what might happen you know if
they go into martial law they can't get
to the markets or have food they're
gonna resort to probably looting other
people houses or whatnot so I just
rather be safe than sorry I know
everyone's scared right now and they're
uncertain so what you're going to
experience is people preparing
themselves it's not a bunch of
vigilantes it's just people who are
concerned about protecting their
families ammunition is also in short
supply ammo is ridiculous about an hour
ago we got in an order of six thousand
nine millimeters they're already gone
owners say 90% are new buyers including
many Asian Americans I have already
encountered people who tell me to stay
inside wash my hands get out here these
panic gun sales are not gonna cure
anything they're not gonna put food on
the table for anybody law enforcement
fears new buyers mean more accidents if
you have one in the home these secured
it safely it's locked it's inaccessible
to anyone most gun buyers only have to
pass a background check not true here in
California nine other states which
require a waiting period three to ten
days so for these people concerned about
the corona virus and its fallout they'll
have to wait Bret William thank you